[Music]
hey come in Dayton Ohio where the
freight trains rumbled through the
streets and the Convention Center looks
like an extremely large glass from the
Pottery Barn Hank as you can tell from
the speckled grey walls behind me I'm in
an airport wait I'm not in an airport
I'm in a hotel before I started
Brotherhood 2.0 I never really realized
the ubiquity of the grey speckled wall
great speckled walls are like the
squirrels of commercial interiors which
is to say that there's so many of them
that you have to wonder if maybe they're
trying to take over by the way Hank do I
hear an anagram and joke anagram joke no
yes you do okay great
you know why people in Dayton Ohio use
Google it's because Dayton Ohio anagrams
- I don't Yahoo nerd jokes nerd jokes
nerd jokes so the reason that I'm in
Dayton is that I'm at a library
conference and look what I got from
nerdfighter library woman Hank it's a
button that says don't forget to be
awesome hey Hank you know who didn't
forget to be awesome yesterday you
seriously Hank that was my favorite
Brotherhood 2.0 song ever I mean Hank
you made party blowers play the tetris
song so anyway Hank I'm giving two
presentations today and right now in
between presentations which means that
I'm kind of doubly nervous because in
addition to being nervous that I just
gave a bad speech I'm nervous that I'm
about to give a bad speech and when I
get nervous like this there's nothing
that I can do about it I mean what can I
do right now to calm myself down I mean
I guess I could listen to party blower
solo
Wow I feel so much less nervous now
Hank the party bull or solo is like
anti-anxiety medication without any of
the side effects Hank I don't want to
overstate the importance of the party
blower solo but I think if we played it
to enough people in Israel and Palestine
it could potentially result in a
sensible two-state solution can we just
like maybe one more time it's coming yes
here it is here it is
I have to tell you Hank the people
walking by or looking at me a little
funny right now
but I don't care I'm completely
unselfconscious because of the party
blower solo Hank in parting I have a
question for you is there a way to take
the audio from the party blower solo and
to make it into an mp3 file and then
would there be a way to implant that mp3
file into my mind and if so is there any
way that the mp3 file in my mind can
play on a continuous loop for the rest
of my life don't forget to be awesome
Hank I'll see you tomorrow
honestly it occurs to me that telling
you not to forget to be awesome is like
telling Tom Selleck not to forget his
mustache
pS Hank three quick congratulations
first to you for being published in the
New York Times this Sunday second to
nerdfighter fall of autumn distro who
had a video on the front page of YouTube
this weekend and third - nerdfighter
Sara Zarr whose first novel story of a
girl is a finalist for the National Book
Award
hooha